[Music]
mila is from ukraine
and uh these guys these gritty rich
people they went and raised over 34
million dollars to help
in humanitarian aid in the ukraine
temporary housing for the refugees
according to the couple's gofundme page
acunus was born in ukraine in 1983 moved
to the united states when she was eight
years old she says ukrainians are proud
and brave people who deserve our help in
their time of need and so these greedy
rich people she and ashton they got
together with some other greedy rich
people
and made a bunch of donations the nerve
i can't believe they helped people with
their money that's awful they're giving
a bad name to the greedy rich people
so uh
mila and ashton created the fundraising
page mark march third made a personal
donation
see here they here they and then they
told people they did it so they're just
awful they three million dollars they
put into their own money
then more than 65 000 donors have
contributed to the campaign the list of
top contributors includes some of the
world's greediest wealthiest individuals
billionaire larry ellison the chairman
of oracle
he donated 5 million because he's a
greedy rich guy
silicon valley
private equity firm dst global greedy
rich people they contributed three
million dollars
and the family foundation of dst partner
yuri milner gave another two and a half
million dollars uh so that's like man
that's like five and a half million
dollars from the dst group alone but
they're all gritty rich people we know
about that
uh another two and a half million
donation came from the family of
renowned silicon valley angel investor
ron conway fashion model uh carl uh is
it carly kloss i think it's close close
i think thank you well i'm not that
happy i'm i'm one degree hipper this is
a fashion model which is two things i
don't know anything about fashion or
models so uh josh
josh kushner uh donated 250 000 through
his foundation he's a venture capitalist
another one of those greedy rich people
and so uh we're overwhelmed with
gratitude for this support from the
greedy rich people said ashton kutcher
didn't say that last part i added it and
in an instagram post on march 17th our
collective greedy rich people effort
will provide a softer landing for many
people as they forge ahead to their
future of uncertainty humanitarian aid
and temporary housing for ukrainian
refugees brought to you by
greedy rich people wow
and i'm on the site now i'm looking at
the gofundme they're up to over 36
million dollars with over almost 76 000
donations precisely more than 36 million
36 million dollars more than the us
government has given oh yeah to help
ukrainian refugees but the gritty rich
people they're doing something about
disgusting and inspiring did the broke
people send money
you know i it doesn't say is there a
broke people page i don't think that's
on here but i guess broke you know if
there's a broke people go funding donate
page yeah you can donate as little as
you can put the change out of every
dollar that you don't use and so you
could send a nickel or seven cents or
you know that kind of stuff and i'm sure
it'll change their life
but the greedy rich people dropped in 36
million so um they went first just
wanted you to know that those people are
out there and they're horrible and
you know we don't we don't we don't
endorse that kind of generosity because
it gives greedy rich people a bad name
we're here to make them look good not
bad do you recognize the sarcasm font in
my voice i hope so although some people
listening may not understand it
well the hang around you'll get it after
a while